the staff are navy grandson developed
hopper bolkiak leaves google and that
today you can talk about a really cool resource
for those who like fitness or who gives
more precise details about the
daily information of your users
and are the peace sensors or step sensors
in English
they are added after 19 on android
4.4 Kitkat they are based on
accelerometers the device is sound
radar sensors and with that were
designed by it to have a low consumption
battery because you're going to do
application does not end up with the
your user since this is not what you
in fact, and it's also smart to
sufficient to detect when it is peace
true or when the sun is in a car
or are you on a bicycle bus workout?
something that is not in fact
truck first time let's talk here is
the rock step detector is activated
when a step is detected informing the
value of return of this sensor is because
an event happens on the part of the deputy
and you in your code can listen to this
two-way sensor continuously
or a block in clash
the first would be when
continuous way by putting the garbage in
looking for elly with max of law equal to
zero
this way once a detected step
your code already notified you must
make the logics or the schedules that
are necessary because you have the
expected result but if you do not
need information exactly at the moment
where it happens you can use the
shape is ibet or in block
for this just put the max of law
such as five seconds
then the maximum time of five seconds
after that step you will be
notified of the steps that have taken place
but of course it remains a
event for Easter so be a good
Android player and just ask for an event on
You really need this.
way it will save even more
user battery
o other sensor is the step counter
it works much like the detector at
difference that he accumulates the steps
Ever since you started listening to the trash
huh
Okay, so he has a little more
latent because he has this
positioning but it produces less
false positives
and can also be listened to by two
ways continued in block or the mother
had seen in previous ones and you want
start using sensors the first
step is to put depends on the version
it's 19 at the beginning of the cave as I said
you say it was taken on android 4.4 and
also put the following already thing that
you will use it
the steppe yesterday the system detects but I will
think you do not have it like
main fitch has come down from your app
so let's put it in the manifesto
you can do this and the pec of energy
this way you will prevent the
user does not download the application if he
does not have this sensor but can give a
Well, it was a nice fit for the person who already
sensor available on your device
good customer use personal sensor has
what to do the right way
you can decide two ways to
first is to receive the events only
while ep is running ok
In this case you will need to take care of yourself.
even the life cycle then recording
edis registering your list according to
with the active rotation re-creation
device is suspended or disabled.
something like that there in case you
to listen to the police is even when the cpu
suspended in the background
It's also possible to just remember to treat
queue of events other than this
do not overflow
an overload of this queue as it goes
accumulate events directly
it is up to you to avoid
chatted and laughed for your app
How does this example come from?
of steps where I received the notification
a sensor dye so that a step
it is in this example that we are
seeing that I am accumulating the steps of
according to an event and the vélez of that face
Why then only one year
you can make another code yourself
find it necessary in your application or I
I can also do the step counter
remembering that you are accumulating value and I
I can do this through value in
position 0 of the event
Good people, that way, you?
can get information about the
activity
the users on how much it he
walked what else he did with his
application and device
So enjoy and good walk from
next staff